[音楽]わずか数十年前と比べてテクノロジーがどれだけ進歩したかは驚くべきことだと思いませんか。
この古い
コンピューターを
見てください。おそらく20〜30年前に、
より強力でスリムな機能を備えた最新のモデルを見てください。
ハード
ウェア
の具体的な性質は
、ソフトウェアよりも重要であるという印象を与えますが、
実際には
、ハードウェアの動作と処理方法を指示するソフトウェアであるという印象を与え
ます。 情報だからこそ
、コンピューティングとマシンの世界は、ハードウェアとソフトウェア
の並行した進歩によって特徴付けられ
ます。残念ながら、最後のアップグレードが
ハードウェアに関して
は、ホモサピエンの登場以来アップグレードがなかったのはいつですか。
約20万年前の種なので、
ハードウェアの設計に関しては
、この現在のモデルに固執して、
さらに進歩させました。  s人間の種と
は
、オペレーティングシステムOS Homo sapiensでソフトウェアを操作
することだけ
を
意味するので、このオペレーティングシステムとは何ですか？ 私たちの周り
の非常に複雑な現実をフィルタリングするレンズは
、世界についての基本的なストーリーを教えてくれます。それは
基本的な情報の仮定の信念
を私たちに提供し、とりわけそれは私たちの行動に影響を与えます。
私たちの共有
オペレーティングシステムに入るタイプの情報しかし問題は
、科学の世界観は、最近の科学の進歩にもかかわらず、数百年前の科学革命の間に出現した現実を見る
非常に機械的な物質的な方法に基づいているという
ことです 支持
されているこれらの仮定の多くは、
誤った科学と私たちのオペレーティングシステムを拡張してこの世界観を保持していることを示しています
非常に時代遅れの現実の不完全な見方に固執するまで
、私は今日ここにいて
、オペレーティングシステムとこの新しいバージョンのソフトウェアをアップグレードする必要があることを私たち全員が主張します。
地球と私たち自身を見ると、
物質的および非物質的な現象を説明できなければなら
ず
、グローバルで平和で持続可能な文明を構築するために必要な行動の変化をもたらすことが
できなければなりませ
ん。 私たちのオペレーティングシステムの現在のバージョンは、
これが私たちが世界を見るように言われている方法です
人間社会を分割するこれらの恣意的な政治的境界でこれらすべての色を見てください
この写真には地球の市民のための場所がありません
これは私たちにもっと支払うことを奨励します
私たちの類似点ではなく、私たちの違いに注意を払う少なくとも
国間の競争
は、搾取や戦争にさえつながる
場合があります。
私たちの
オペレーティングシステムが教えてくれないのは、この世界を見ることができるということです。
宇宙から
見える政治的境界はほとんどない
ので、国際宇宙ステーションから帰国した宇宙飛行士
は、地球と人類の見方が
地球を上から見た結果、根本的に変化し
た著者フランク・ホワイト彼は、この
変化する知覚を
現在の概観効果と呼んでいます。
親和性の感覚
すべての人間とすべての生命体
との相互接続の感覚そしてこれは地球全体の環境を
世話する必要があるという責任感につながる
ので、これは地球と私たち自身を見る非常に包括的な方法です
確かに
私はオペレーティングシステムのアップグレードにプログラムする必要があると思いますが、
地球は今生きていますこれは基本的な
質問です その上で、地球に対する私たちの態度と扱いを決定します。
現在のオペレーティングシステムは
、地球は今死んで
いることを示しています。はい、地球には生命がありますが
、統合された全体としての自然
は、生きている存在とは見なされません。
正確なのは、この話は
本当に奇妙なことです。
私たちが自然を生きていると見なした人類の歴史の大部分で自然が生きているという考えは
、沈没したり、日本の宗教
は自然を動物であり、世界中の
無数の先住民の神でいっぱいだと考え
ています。
自然だけでなく、地球と
宇宙全体が生きていると考え、ヨーロッパ人
は数百年前までは
真実であると考えています。私
たちは自然も
生きていると考えていました。 そのため、一部の
森林は魅了される魔法の力を持っていると見なされ
、
この不思議な自然観は
、それが防ぐ行動に大きな影響を与えました。
たとえば、短期間の物質的利益の
ために広大な森林を伐採することから私たちを
導きましたが、
現在のオペレーティングシステムは、このように自然を表示していません。
これは、最初の世界を
機械的に表示する方法を継承しています。
ここに示されているアイザック・ニュートンなどの偉大な科学者に受け継がれているのは、世界
が
巨大な時計の歯車や車輪のように機能する巨大な魂のない機械である
ため、彼の世界観の性質を継承
する
ことは、かつては魂が剥ぎ取られていた自然でした
基本的な構成要素が単に
原子分子とエネルギーである純粋な物理的現象に至るまで、現在の
オペレーティングシステムは
、森林や地球の広い領域などの自然
は基本的に死んでいる物質の塊で
あり、これは私たちに
先に進んでその問題を
物質的な利益のために利用する知的正当化なので、もちろん
、Scientific R以来、私たちは目覚ましい物質的な進歩を遂げてきました
進化論ですが、私たち
はこの気候変動のために自然を犠牲にしまし
た惑星全体での動物種の喪失
天然
資源の枯渇海洋でのプラスチックの蓄積
これらはすべて
不健康な人間の自然関係の兆候であり、
この背後には
不健康な方法があります 自然を見るということは、
私たちのオペレーティングシステムが自然が生きていると私たちに教えてくれた場合、科学者が根本的に新しいビジョンを提供し始めていることが判明した
ので、おそらく私たちはそれを別の方法で扱うかもしれません
個々の
樹木は、コミュニティが
生命と知性に溢れ、
さらには協力の場となっています。現在、
樹木は実際に互いに協力し合っており、
互いに炭素を共有しています。
これは、大気から吸収された炭素で
あり、ルートシステムを通じて他の樹木と共有されます。
土壌中の菌類の協力今、
あなたができる科学者スザンヌ・サマールc ヘック
は、カナダのブリティッシュコロンビア州の森林で画期的な研究を行った方法によるTEDプレゼンテーションで、彼女の本当に素晴らしいプレゼンテーションを行いました。
ここ
では、炭素床のネットワーク分析の分析を通じて、彼女のチーム
が、彼女が呼んでいる大きなモミの木を発見しまし
た。 母木は
積極的に炭素を
親族から赤ちゃん
、林床の苗木に送っています。これ
により、これらの苗木の生存率が約4倍になります。そのため、
ここには、自然がはるかに不可欠であることを示唆する魅力的な科学的証拠があります。
相互接続された
インテリジェンスと生きているより良い言葉の欠如のために、
私たちの現在のオペレーティング
システムは私
たちのOSホモサピエンスの別の問題を考えてみましょう私
たちの現在のバージョンは心
と体がキャンプであり、体が
完全に分離していることを私たちに伝えますこれはアイデアです
ここに示されているルネ・デカルトの非常に影響力のあるアイデアから科学に現れたので、私を継承します s世界
観科学は人間の有機体を
基本的に機械と見なし、
その研究を2つの
別々の分野に編成します。
医学は身体の研究であり、
心理学は
現在どちらの分野の医師でもあります。
その分野だけを専門としている
ので、彼らは体と心の相互関係にあまり注意を払っていません。
科学は
、精神的ストレスが現れる可能性があることを私たちが知っている心と体のジュリースティックビューの問題を理解し始めています。
身体的苦痛として、これ
は例えば
高血圧や消化器系の問題を引き起こす可能
性があることを私たちは知っています、そして逆に私たちは心を落ち着かせること
が時々例えば瞑想を通してこれらの問題に対処できることを知ってい
ます これの究極の
例は、プラセボ効果
に関する最も魅力的な研究の1つで
あり、この研究です。  at
は米国で行われ、これ
は膝関節炎を患った約165人を対象とした実験であり、
現在患者は3
つのグループに分けられ、そのうち2人は
膝関節を手術し
、膝軟骨を剃る
か流動性のある本物の手術を受けました。 膝関節に流された
が、3番目のグループ
は完全に偽の手術を受けたプラセボグループでしたが、膝関節
が切り開かれた手術室に連れて行かれました
が、医師は
手術のふりをして患者に2年しか言われませんでした
後で彼らの手術が
本物であるかどうかにかかわらず、
この2期間全体で
、完全に偽の手術を受けたプラセボグループが
同じ程度に治癒し、実際の手術を受け
た他の2つのグループよりもわずかに良くなったと想像できますか？
ここで驚くべき証拠
は、第一に体の心がしっかりと
相互に関連していること、そして第二に心がしっかりと相互に関連していることを疑いの余地なく証明してい
ます
場合によって
は手術や薬よりも物理的な治癒過程で重要な役割を果たすため、この
知識は不完全です。
より多くの研究が必要ですが、確か
に人間の心と体のこの新しい統合されたビジョンは、
科学ができるように私たちのオペレーティングシステムのアップグレードに入る必要があります
あなたのオペレーティングシステムを豊かにする
ことは、私たちの周りの非常に複雑な相互接続されたインテリジェントな世界への魅力的な新しい洞察を私たちに提供することができます
が、今日の科学は私たちが
必要とするすべての答えを提供することはできません、そして
その理由は
科学が
それが見る現実を見る物質的な方法のためです 心と物質が分離している巨大な魂のない機械として、
これは人間の存在における多くの非物質的な現象を説明することはできません。
たとえば
、ホモサピエンスにとって本当に重要な質問
を考えてみましょう。あなた
は私たちの多くが行う魂を持っていると思いますか 宗教
は、あなたが死んだときにあなたの魂に何が起こるかを私たちがうまくやっていると私たちに伝えてい
ます
それはChのように天国に行きますか
人間の存在のリスティアンの概念
またはそれはリサイクルされますかそれは仏教徒のように生まれ変わります
かまたは生まれ変わりのヒンズー教の考えでは
残念ながら科学
はこの質問に答えることができません
しかし、幸いなことに、魂
は科学に存在しません。
幸いなことに、これらの大きな問題
に取り組み始めている科学者はごくわずかで
あり、彼らの
研究
は、人間の心と
体の現在の理解がおそらく完全に間違って
いることを示しています。
有名な医学雑誌TheLancet
は、オランダ全土の病院に持ち込まれ
た心臓停止で死亡した約340人の患者の死後の経験の研究を含みましたが、
後に医療チームによって復活し
ました。これらの患者へのインタビューで
明らかになりました。 約5分の
1がそう経験したこと
-このサブグループの現在の臨死体験
と
呼ばれるものは、約半分が死んでいることに気付いていると
主張し、約3分の1が、死んだ後
、ある種のトンネルを通過した
か、反対側で亡くなった知人に会ったと主張しています。
彼らはある種の天国の風景を見ていましたが
、臨床的に死んでいると診断された後、これらすべてが起こったの
です。
彼らの脳は機能していない必要
があります。彼らの脳は血液と酸素
が不足しています。 死体
が治療され
ていたとき、彼は看護師が偽の歯を抜いて片付けているのを経験
したので、
蘇生したときにその看護師を驚かせ、約1
週間後、彼女を見たとき、
彼は偽の歯を元に戻し、彼女
がどこに置いたかを彼女に話しました 偽の歯なので
、他の研究と同様に、これらの研究は
、彼の
患者の場合は機能していなかった脳が
おそらく私たちの短所の原因ではないことを示唆しています
意識今これは
おそらく
死後の世界があるかもしれないという人間の魂があることを示して
いますこれは
不完全な知識ですが確かに心と体
の人間の存在のこの不可欠な見方
は私たちの運営のアップグレードに入るはずです システムとして、私たち
はローカルとしてのコミュニティとして、そしてグローバルコミュニティとして、
共有インテリジェンスのタイプについての会話を開始する
必要があります。私たちの種を未来に導くために必要なオペレーティングシステムのタイプ
オペレーティングシステム
は不完全で時代遅れであり
、人間の存在における非物質的な現象を説明することはでき
ません。精神的な発達を促進することは何もせず
、非常に複雑で
洗練されたインテリジェントな
自然の働きを説明できないことがよくあります。
新しい課題が発生したり
、世界への新しい知識が生まれたりするたびに、オペレーティングシステムを何度も更新する必要があります。  und us
が出現したので、皆さんへの私の質問
は、皆さんの新しいオペレーティングシステムはどのようなもので
あり、それがどのように世界を皆さんに見せるかということ
です。これは、すべてのホモサピエンスにとっての課題です。
ありがとうござい
ます。